hey everybody just probably get into it
today there are going to be a lot of
Italian pronunciations in this one I'm
doing my best
a dear kind of writer for this script
has even spelled about phonetically for
me I've also got my free let's see Asian
dictionary right here I am doing my best
[Music]
so on this channel we've covered the
lives of a lot of Nazi officers and Nazi
officials and this is always what we've
forgotten about their axis allies on the
other side of the Alps the Italian
fascists the history may not be as
well-known as the lives of other
protagonists of World War two and yet I
can assure you they had some interesting
characters marching about in their back
shirted uniforms since Mussolini founded
the fascist movement in 1919 one of them
was today's protagonist Roman
aristocrats with a taste for action a
pioneer of naval special forces of
military leader loyal to Mussolini's
regime and the mastermind behind one of
the most puzzling cooze
ever the video today well that's the
story of you neo valerio borghese the
black prince of fascism
[Music]
before we start let's clarify a couple
of points point number one at the time
of the fascist regime and world war two
Italy was a monarchy and Mussolini
shared leadership of the country with
King Victor Emmanuel the third but even
if today's protagonist was styled as
Prince he was not the king's son he was
not even related to him in any way and
certainly had no claims to the throne in
certain countries such as Italy or
Russia before the 1917 revolution it
could happen that certain high-ranking
Nobles were titled princes without
having any royal lineage point number
two the nickname of Black Prince was
only given to Borghese after the war
because of the black shirt used as a
basic uniform by members of the fascist
party and the militia during the war he
was actually known as the Frog Prince
because his tactics relied heavily on
the use of frogmen but Frog Prince a
kind of sounds like the title of a
Disney movie and this guy was certainly
no hero from a fairy tale plus there's
also the fact that Black Prince sounds a
whole lot cooler all right with that out
of the way let's crack on
[Music]
baby you neo was born in artena close to
Rome Italy on probably the most
unfortunate date ever
the 6th of June 1906 all right so before
you'll go and get excited about a
fascist Prince of Darkness being born
literally on the day carrying the number
of the beast
just consider that he came into an old
aristocratic family at the Borghese s
who could boast Napoleon's brother in
law and a pope among their ancestors
moreover he was baptised with probably
the most unfortunate name ever you neo
Valeria sheep your net grace toh
Marcantonio maria his father princely vo
Borghese was a diplomat and therefore
young you neo grew up and studied first
in Great Britain and then Portugal and
then finally back in Rome as a
second-born son he knew it was not going
to inherit either his family's wealth
nor the small castle in our Taner so he
had to find his own place in the world
tradition dictated that non firstborn
sons in the aristocracy made their
fortune either in the clergy or in the
military you neo chose the latter
enrolling in the leave or noir Naval
Academy in 1928 he graduated with the
rank of midshipman with a specialization
in submarine warfare and an underwater
diving certificate under his belt in
1931 he married Russian countess Darya
Wessel Rhea Olson five the couple would
go on to have four children
Elinor Paolo levy or and Andrea she ray
as a military man had grown very close
to Mussolini's ideology and regime
especially with the fear and hatred of
communism which was actually one of the
few traits shared by hardline fascists
and the Italian aristocracy but most of
all he was inspired by the extreme
nationalism of the do chase policies
these sought to establish an Italian
sphere of influence from the Adriatic to
the southern Mediterranean a powerful
navy was vital to that objective when
it's at least Navy the rager marina
rented World War 2 in June of 1948
outnumbered the combines British and
French fleets in the Mediterranean a
hundred and eighty-five vessels to 144
although it suffered from a chronic lack
of fuel however back in the 1930s
Italian shipyards were still lagging
behind the British both in quality and
quantity of vessels young officers like
Borghese proposed speed stealth and
daring as an alternative
this meant investing in building small
assault vessels manned by highly trained
commandos the chief example of this new
tactical approach was the SLC the human
torpedo
the human torpedoes had been perfected
by naval engineers Tessie Otis I and
Elias toski who had nicknamed them the
my ally or pigs because of their strange
grunting noise basically these were
miniature submarines on which two
frogmen could sit astride they were
propelled by a small electric motor and
the frogmen of the fronts were in charge
of steering their tactic was to
infiltrate enemy ports at night
approached their target ship and
attached a magnetic mine to the hull it
sort of begs for a bit of an instagram
name doesn't it who would win a
battleship or two dudes on a banana boat
surprisingly though it worked they sank
a total of 200,000 tons of Allied
shipping in the Mediterranean theater
alone this was so much of a problem that
the British Royal Navy actually stole
the idea but we decided to call them
chariots because pigs didn't sound
classy enough during the Spanish Civil
War Prince Borghese was able to build up
experience in stealth submarine warfare
he led several illegal actions bordering
on piracy intended to damage neutral
navies supplying the legitimate
Republican Spanish government on the
night of the 30th of August 1937 aboard
the submarine e'r'day Borghese went one
step too far he ordered a torpedo attack
against what appeared to be a Republican
ship it wasn't it was the British
destroyer HMS Havelock the torpedoes
missed its mark and Havelock gave chase
joined by three more destroyers and a
light cruiser
despite the first ever use of sonar in
wartime ins the deployment of depth
charges the sneaky Prince evaded his
pursuers and landed safely in Naples on
sub time of the fifth but the ensuing
scandal it put an end to all submarine
activities off the Spanish coast meaning
Borghese had to wait for at least two
years
before going back into action On June
the 10th 1940 Mussolini declared war on
France and the United Kingdom
on the 12th of June the British light
cruiser Calypso was sunk off the coast
of Crete by an Italian submarine and
with that the Battle of the
Mediterranean had begun principal gaze a
had progressed in the ranks and was now
a Corvette captain in charge of the
submarine sheer a his unit was part of
the tenth flight flotilla the Special
Forces of the Italian Navy known as the
date Jima
mas where mas stands for their motto and
Latin momento or dare SM
remember today always the Shira is modus
operandi was to sneak as close as
possible to enemy ports in the
Mediterranean to launch two or three
human torpedoes and sink allied vessels
and this is how they scored a
strategically significant victory for
gazes greatest military success on the
19th of December 1941 three of his pigs
launched off the sheer a and entered
into the port of Alexandria Egypt they
were undetected the frogmen made contact
with their targets the battleships HMS
valiant since HMS Queen Elizabeth and
they placed their explosive charges the
British sailors captured and
interrogated to have all gays these men
but they would not reveal the nature of
their mission until the last possible
moment
they revealed the presence of the mines
allowing for most of the crew to
disembark to safety when the charges
went off valiant Queen Elizabeth and two
other ships sank in the shallow waters
of Alexandria overnight the Axis navies
had gained strategic superiority albeit
temporarily across the Mediterranean
borghese went on to clock up more
successes with the sheer a sinking or
damaging a total of 90,000 131 tons of
Allied shipping during the Battle of the
Mediterranean on the 1st of May 1943
burrkc was promoted to the rank of
ship-of-the-line captain and
commander-in-chief of the 10th mas
shortly afterwards on the 25th of July
Benito Mussolini was deposed and
arrested in a military coup backed by
King Victor Emmanuel the 3rd for a short
period the Italian army continued its
fight alongside Germany until on the 8th
of September Mussolini's successor Field
Marshal battle II were announced
completely unexpectedly that Italy had
signed an armistice with the Allies the
country was split in two and found
itself plunged into a civil war on top
of the one that it was already fighting
the southern half was loyal to the king
and Baddeley where its armed forces saw
the Germans as the invaders and as such
they sided with the Allies in the
northern half the Germans and diehard
fascists had installed Mussolini at the
head of a newly founded Italian social
Republic this saw the Allies as the
invaders and so it maintained its
alliance with the Nazis Prince Borghese
decided to continue fighting on the
German side although he gave his men
freedom of choice and awarded to
everybody an unrestricted order of leave
in case some of them wanted to join the
king in the south his behavior so far it
was quite honourable although what
maybe opens you a rather different
interpretation on the 14th of September
he signed an agreement with Nazi Germany
which effectively made him autonomous
from Mussolini's newly founded Republic
yet it placed the tenth mas in direct
control of the German military as a
result during the following two years
Borghese mainly assigned his men to land
operations more precisely these were
counterinsurgency operations at the
behest of ss general Karl Wolfe intended
to cripple the anti-fascist resistance
in northern Italy during this period of
the sailors now foot soldiers of the
10th mas garnered a reputation as
ruthless killers and torturers of
guerrilla fighters and civilians alike
in the spring of 1945 when it was clear
that the war with the Allies was lost
General Wolfe met in Switzerland with a
representative of the OSS the CIA's
predecessor in order to negotiate a
separate truce one of those requests was
for Borghese to receive honorable
treatment what this really meant was
just to spare him reprisals from the
resistance the OSS kept their word on
the 24th of April 1945 the war in Italy
was formally over and Borghese but the
sneaky prince made it unscathed to Rome
disguised as an American officer on the
30th of April 1945 the now democratic
authorities in Italy apprehended
principal Casey and charged him with
being a collaborator of the Nazi
occupation after three years he was
finally trialed in February of 1949 and
sentenced to 12 years in jail once again
the OSS though they came to the rescue
they lobbied the magistrates to reduce
the sentence to three years which he had
rarely spent in jail waiting for the
trial so Prince you knew Valerio etc etc
boy hazy it was now as free as a bird at
this point in history the Americans were
in need of the right people and by that
we mean right-wing people to be active
in Italy in balancing their perceived
threat of a communist takeover having
quit the military the prince channeled
his nationalistic and anti-communist
fervor into politics first he joins the
msi the Italian social movements a
right-wing party considered to be the
heir of the fascist party Borghese
became the honorary president of the msi
but his rabid rhetoric and his desire
for action it clashed with the party
leadership basically the leadership dude
want this because they wanted to improve
their image with the general public
therefore the prince decided to found
his own extremist far-right movements
called the National Front during this
period Borghese became a sort of
spiritual leader for young neo-fascists
especially one stefano delle Kyoya this
guy he was from the national Vanguard
faction a terrorist group that espoused
an ideology of violent actions counter
communism and the perceived influence of
the Soviet Union in Italy's internal
affairs so we actually had the
opportunity to speak with a retired
government official who met Prince
Borghese and private several times in
the 1960s for this video he said
militarily speaking he certainly did
accomplish a lot until 1941 but I always
found it curious that he finished the
war with a rank equivalent to colonel
relatively low for a 39 year old in a
period of high mortality rate amongst
officers after the war I had the dubious
fortune of meeting the prince in private
as I was friends with one of his sons
and my father was active in the MSI poor
hazy had a gift for inflammatory
rhetoric but deep down you could tell
that the man was full of himself
during the 1960's Italy was Grips in the
so-called years of let a period of
tension in which left and right wing
terrorist groups like carried out
attacks against the state and civilian
victims well Casey it was not gonna
stand back and watch he was going to see
his power the first official record of
preparations for a coup d'etat can be
traced back to the 11th of May 1969
according to an inquiry from rai Italian
public TV on that day in Geneva Borghese
had a secret meeting with a group of
influential captains of industry to
secure funds for his anti-communist and
anti-democratic coup among them even one
mr. P Andrew yep the same guy who
brought you the Vespa next step was to
ask them do you want to prevent a
foreign power
that's the Soviet Union from messing
with your country well then we should
get help from another foreign power that
would be the US of A so Borghese
dispatched his associate Adriano Mountie
an army doctor to meet another unsavory
character in Madrid Otto Skorzeny this
former Nazi and SS commando was famous
for rescuing Mussolini from captivity in
1943 in a raid conducted by glider this
gentleman had escaped nuremberg after
the war and was thriving in Francoist
Spain he also enjoyed a good
relationship with the CIA during their
meeting scores any reassured Monti that
the US would be supportive of the coup
as it was part of their cold war
strategy to establish a belt of reliable
authoritarian governments in southern
Europe to prevent the Warsaw Pact from
gaining access to the Mediterranean
think about it by the late 1960s
Portugal Spain and Greece runs a
military dictatorships Italy was sort of
the last piece of the puzzle plans for
the coup were ready for Casey and his
co-conspirators managed to draft in
general Mitch Halley head of the
military secret services and on the
other end of the spectrum there was some
mafiosi whose job it was to assassinate
the chief of police finally the Prince
pre-recorded a radio address to the
nation which read the long awaited coup
has taken place the Armed Forces the
police all the most competent men in
this country are all on our side our
most dangerous foes those who want to
enslave Italy a foreign powers have been
made harmless
long live Italy the action codenamed
operation tora tora took place on the
7th and 8th of december 1970 in the
shape of a multi-pronged attack
- the main institutions on the 7/3
detachments of 50 national Vanguard
thugs headed by Delhi chikage snuck
undetected into the Ministry of the
Interior in Rome and stole a cache of
200 submachine guns the same night an
armored battalion under the orders of
Colonel Piazza occupied strategically
important barracks and says strode
northern Italy also a famous communist
stronghold in the early hours of the 8th
Colonel Bertie led a motorized column to
seize the main officers of public TV and
radio in Rome but his men we're not
soldiers they were forest guards Park
Rangers in other words why well kind of
beats me but I mean at least they were
armed all seem to be set for Borghese to
turn Italy into another military
dictatorship but then everything
collapsed it just melted away first kind
of Bertie met two shadowy figures in
front of the TV officers according to a
witness the two men who appeared to be
members of the military intelligence
told him to go home boss's orders then
the national Vanguard thugs who
apparently had received the same orders
snuck back into the ministry and
returned the submachine guns however
they only returns 199 keeping one as a
souvenir
finally Colonel Piazza retreated to
turns out at the last minute the Black
Prince had given the order to abort the
coup but why well according to one of
the prosecutors who investigated the
coup in the following years a audio
vitelloni
this was the intention from the start
the coup was just a bluff intended to
provoke a tough reaction from the
governments in the hope that it declared
martial law to crack down on the
conspirators effectively becoming an
authoritarian regime in the process the
truth has never been established in a
definitive way some even claiming that
the coup never actually took place the
investigations proved inconclusive
resulting in the prosecution of some
national Vanguard terrorists but most
were acquitted including the vespa guy
and those other industrialists whatever
it was that happened that night luckily
it didn't work and Italy remained a
democracy
now let's get back to the night of
December the 8th in his headquarters
after giving the order to retreat while
Casey stretched his right hands to his
accomplices branding himself a traitor
he demanded for a pistol to shoot
himself but he did not receive one and
as he lived on the most incredible thing
about this coup is that apparently
nobody had noticed that it had even
taken place it took an article published
in March of 1971 for the public opinions
you finally realize that Italy was
heading towards banana
Republic status when the news broke the
Black Prince left for a self-imposed
exile he moved to Spain as many other
former Nazis and fascists officials had
done before him after a spell in
Barcelona he moved to southern Spain on
the 26th of August 1974 the Black Prince
junio valerio borghese who had escaped
the clutches of the British Navy first
and the Italian police later could not
fool an acute bout of pancreatitis he
died at the age of 68 leaving behind a
trail of mysteries last but not least
his own death as early as 1975 a
magazine article suggested that he may
have died from arsenic poisoning the
alleged killer beau Casey's own
spiritual a stefano delle Chiaki that
well that's another story for another
day do leave your comments below and let
us know what you think about today's
protagonist war hero war criminal
deluded schemer feel free to share like
subscribe all that good stuff and as
usual thank you for watching
[Music]